don't count your chickens before they're
[Music]
hatched many hands make light
work a bad Penny always turns
up actions speak louder than
[Music]
words you are never too old to
learn a picture is worth a thousand
words absence makes the heart grow
[Music]
fonder grasp no more than thy hand will
hold never judge by
appearances
birds of a feather flock
together half a loaf is better than no
bread if a job is worth doing it is
worth doing
well there is none so blind as those who
will not
see
the early bird catches the
worm honesty is the best
policy into every life a little Rain
Must
Fall beauty is only skin
deep don't don't cross a bridge until
you come to
[Music]
it let bygones be
bygones a stumble May prevent a
fall speak the truth and shame the
devil slow but
sure
don't put all your eggs in one
basket All That Glitters Is Not
Gold the grass is always greener on the
other
side to everything there is a
[Music]
season
as you sow so shall you
reap two wrongs don't make a
right better late than
never you cannot make an omelet without
breaking a few
eggs practice makes perfect
[Music]
there is no time like the
present hope for the best prepare for
the
[Music]
worst you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make him
drink there's no place like home
don't put off until tomorrow what you
can do
[Music]
today a bicycle can't stand on its own
because it's too
tired if you want to judge a man's
character give him
power if wishes were horses Beggars
would
ride a stitch in time saves
nine sticks and stones will break my
bones but names will never hurt
me life is what you make of
it a man is as old old as he feels
himself to
be everyone must row with the ores he
[Music]
has least said soonest
mended a trouble shared is a trouble
[Music]
haved where there's a will there's
away you never know what you can do
until you
try one father is more than a 100 School
Masters success has many fathers failure
is an
orphan one of these days is is none of
these
days elbow grease is the best
polish proportion your expenses to what
you have not what you
[Music]
expect don't try to run before you can
walk worry off often gives a small thing
a big
Shadow all happiness is in the
[Music]
mind nothing ventured nothing
gained it's never too late to
[Music]
mend patience wears away Stu
Stones cheaters never win and winners
never
cheat a good example is the best
sermon some men go through a forest and
see no
firewood do not be in a hurry to tie
what you cannot
[Music]
untie slow and steady wins the
race lose an hour in the morning and
you'll be running after it all
day action is the proper fruit of
knowledge all good things come to to
those who
[Music]
wait a smooth sea never made a skilled
Mariner a word to the wise is
enough after a storm comes the
[Music]
calm halls for the best in the best of
all possible world
[Music]
don't look a gift horse in the
mouth all's well that ends
well an eye for an eye and a tooth for a
tooth any port in a
storm
ashes to ashes dust to
[Music]
dust ask a silly question and you'll get
a silly
[Music]
answer don't let the cat out of the
bag a chain is only as strong as its
weakest
link
the best things in life are
free don't bite the hand that feeds
you better to light a candle than to
curse the
darkness don't cast your pearls before
the
[Music]
swine all's fa in Love and
War the Apple never Falls far from the
tree between two stools one falls to the
[Music]
ground blood is thicker than
water a slice of bread always falls
buttered upside
down business before
[Music]
pleasure children and fools tell the
truth don't meet troubles
halfway a barking dog never
bites
cleanliness is Next to
Godliness a rolling stone gathers no
Moss the cobbler always wears the worst
shoes an englishman's home is his
castle
brevity is the soul of
wit cowards may die many times before
their
deaths The Darkest Hour is just before
the
dawn a fool in his money are soon
parted don't leave your manners on the
[Music]
doorstep doubt is the beginning not the
end of
wisdom empty vessels make the most
noise enough is as good as a
feast a good beginning makes a good
ending
don't put the cart before the
horse every stick has two
ends fish and guests smell after 3
days Fools Rush In Where Angels Fear To
Tread
forwarned is
[Music]
forearmed give the devil his
due good fences make good
neighbors good things come in small
[Music]
packages The Hand That Rocks the Cradle
rules the
[Music]
world hard work never hurt
anyone he who laughs last laughs
best the man who is his own lawyer has a
fool for a
client he who lives by the sword shall
die By The
[Music]
Sword honey catches more flies than
vinegar if you can't beat him join
them if you lie down with dogs you will
get up with
[Music]
fleas a poor Workman always blames his
tools
[Music]
in the land of the blind the oneeyed man
is
King it's no use crying over spilled
milk judge not lest you be
judged keep your friends close and your
enemies closer
let sleeping dogs
lie Mighty Oaks from Little acorns
grow never judge a book by its
cover you can't make bricks without
[Music]
straw don't burn the candle at both
ends you are what you
eat two heads are better than
one where there's muck there's
brass don't cut off your nose in spite
of your
face
a watched pot never
boils if it ain't broke don't fix
it if you play with fire you'll get
[Music]
burned where there's smoke there's
fire a poison tree bears poison
fruit a fool at 40 is a fool
[Music]
forever all cats love fish but hate to
get their paws
[Music]
wet a loaded wagon makes no
noise one rotten apple spoils the whole
Barrel
don't make a mountain out of a mole
[Music]
hill a tree is known by its
fruit don't spit into the
wind a young idler an old
beggar better an egg today than a hen
tomorrow Bloom where you are
planted a fish always rots from the head
down born with a silver spoon in your
[Music]
mouth by hook or by
crook
desperate times call for desperate
measures don't bite off more than you
can
chew the ends justify the
means fool me once shame on you fool me
twice shame on
me
good and quickly seldom
meet a friend in need is a friend
[Music]
indeed haste makes
waste a new broom sweeps
[Music]
clean however long the night
the dawn will
break it takes both rain and sunshine to
make
[Music]
rainbows a penny saved is a penny
earned a nod is as good as a wink to a
blind
horse don't kill the goose that lays the
golden
egg a silent woman is a gift from
God the longest mile is the last one
home misfortunes never come
singly Monkey C Monkey
do
no woman gets an orgasm from shining the
kitchen
[Music]
floor